[Music]
Peter we've heard a lot about the NES
classic but you you finally got to try
it out yeah Nintendo has sort of given
us a chance to play it just yesterday
and as someone who grew up in NES was
born same year was released I've always
sort of had an affinity for it and so in
the analysis I was super excited a great
a nice I collect Nintendo games now so
it was sort of a weird thing for me it's
like do I want the real thing or do I
want this where does it fall for me and
I found that it's sort of somewhere in
the middle so in the NES classic of
course is not this not it does not play
cartridges it comes with them
pre-installed yes and it's also bit
smaller super small I mean it is less
wide than this controller or maybe just
as wide I mean it it is tiny like super
super small so does that mean the build
quality isn't that great is it do you
feel like it holds up is there something
that you'd want to display I mean that's
just it right like it looks like a nice
little model of an NES and you know what
yes it does feel good in practice the
controller especially that's one of the
things that's the most important for
these games is you know responsiveness
and sort of giving you that feeling that
you had playing an original NES and
having done that recently just on my own
the controller that I use yesterday felt
great it feels very much like the same
build quality and I was trying to get
them to talk to me about how they match
to the two they didn't really have all
that info but I can say just for my
experience it feels really good I'm very
pleased about that but the way that the
games look in play is probably the most
important is someone especially for you
you've bought TVs specifically to play
classic games on classic systems yeah
does the emulation hold up to you what
do you think about the way the games
look and play the games look good I mean
they look as best as you'd expect on a
720p TV and it's yes it's upscale but I
think it's up scaled natively so it's
actually rendered at 720p and that's
important because then you don't have
the problems of like input lag and delay
there is the sort of flickering you
would get from an old NES I mean they're
really trying to emulate these
as as true as they can to what they used
to be so there'll be some slowdown but
they're sprites on the screen yes
doesn't make sense but sure yes a little
bit here and there but that that is what
they are and that they're going to be
true to that there are a few modes where
you can play the game
traditionally TVs were you know like
four by three so there was some of these
images would be stretched a tiny bit
depending on your TV you can also play
in a pixel perfect mode which is a
perfect square so every pixel is a
square rather than like slightly
stretched or you can apply scan lines to
the image as well to sort of give you
that CRT like feeling where you had you
know every other line was darker and you
have some of that going on but it's not
the same as playing on a real CRT it's
definitely a different feeling and
depending on your your HDTV as well you
might want to have to worry about things
like game mode or all the digital
processing that goes in to your image
just to make sure that the timing is
correct because these games are really
hard and if you're off even by a couple
frames cause a lot of problems
for the Bucks itself it's it's
streamlined a lot of juice uses a
regular HDMI to plug into your TV and I
guess I think it has a USB yes it's
powered by USB Nintendo wasn't the
people I was speaking with didn't know
if you can actually power it from a USB
port versus a like an AC adapter for USB
cable if it does let you charge through
something like a USB 2.0 port which I
believe carries five volts you should be
able to plug it just into your TVs
service port so then you don't actually
need to have any sort of power
connection and that's great yes there's
no like analog out it's just HTMI and
the controller connects using the same
adapter that the nunchuck used on the
remote and what's great about that is
these controllers which are ten dollars
on their own you can actually use those
to play Virtual Console games on your
Wii U or the week as well and I think
something interesting you mentioned is
that they've replaced the power and
reset buttons with a start and select
and that's kind of how you get into the
quick save options for games yes so
everything runs in an operating system
and it's essentially you're provided
with a stream of covers for the 30 games
that are included so you press what is
the reset button on this to get back to
that screen and so when you're back at
that screen you can choose a new game or
you can make savestates so you can save
at any point in any game that you want
you have four slots for each game you
can lock saves as well so you don't have
a write them by accident it's a bit
disappointing that I can't say hit start
and select on the controller to initiate
a save state I actually have to
physically touch the console itself that
said the controller cable is a little
bit short it's only a few feet maybe
three feet so you're not going to be too
far from this thing in any given time I
guess the most important question is
there are a lot of options for emulating
classic games these days from standalone
systems that run all these old games to
just finding an old NES somewhere and
now the NES classic is this something
you want to buy it like as a collector
is someone who loves playing these old
games or who is this for as someone who
loves the NES I want one of these
because it is a a really nice sort of a
c'mon yumen ton loss to the nes but that
said you know I was playing these games
yesterday and I'm glad to see them all
there there's a lot of excellent games
but I played a lot of these in recent
years I own a lot of them already so as
a collector I don't feel like I'm going
to be missing out if I don't buy this
right away but that said I would like to
have one and I can definitely imagine
you know for someone who doesn't play
these games today this is gonna be an
excellent little package and it's like
the perfect gift for anyone you know
late 20s early 30s and I'm really
curious to see how it maybe the younger
generation is gonna pick it up as well
yeah I wish you'd had an internet
connectivity like I wish that you could
download other games or was tied somehow
into your virtual conference library cuz
I have a lot of these games already yes
but that would be nice but I mean it's
60 bucks it's pretty cheap and you get
30 games for that and yeah unfortunately
there's no way to expand it a Nintendo
is not gonna be releasing carts that
give you more games and like you said
there's no internet and no no tying in
to your shop account but when did it
come out in November and I think there
it's sold out already pre-orders the
next wave that opens you're gonna be
able to preorder it and you should get
it before Christmas but this is like a
classic like system launch now like this
thing is selling out how it's done
interesting a nice Christmas gift would
be to buy one of these the original ones
and put the NES classic inside of it so
you have to open up the NES classic it's
not a bad idea that's a good gift idea
[Music]